l'Eure-et-Loir pour te répondre c'est le
pire désert de France toute la France
est un désert il y a plus de médecins à
Paris il y a plus de mettre en PACA ta
coiffeuse tout à l'heure on discuté
amusé ma sœur à Charenton elle a pas de
médecins donc on arrête de dire que
c'est un problème de campagne et c'est
un problème qui dure depuis 20 ans ça
fait 20 ans qu'on dit ça fait 20 ans
qu'on n'en peux plus nous dans la dans
le département on a mis plein d'actions
bénévoles en dehors de notre temps de
travail pour essayer de lutter contre le
désert médical
toutes les solutions qui ont été
proposées par les politiques jusqu'à
maintenant ça n'a jamais marché ça on le
fait tous le constat parce que si les
solutions répondaient au problème vous
auriez des médecins d'accord et quand on
appelle à l'aide et quand on dit qu'on
peut plus travailler qu'on est
complètement débordé il y a de
l'agression constante
les gens n'ont pas de médecin traitant
les gens ne peuvent pas soigner Cyril
c'est fou je veux dire quoi on va
rappeler combien combien coûte une
consultation chez un médecin généraliste
c'est 25 mais c'est nous on a aucune
revendication salariale
c'est que lui il est volontaire pour
assurer des gardes il fait des gardes il
se fait agresser il se fait agresser par
les patients il dit il sait les médecins
volontaires disent moi nous on peut plus
bosser dans ces conditions là faut
assurer notre sécurité quelle est la
réponse des préfets on envoie les
gendarmes pour les réquisitionner pour
les conditions de la sécurité on règle
rien ils ont envoyé des fonds pour
réquisitionner alors que nos jeunes
consœurs qu'on la boule au ventre en
allant en garde et qu'on peut plus et on
le redit l'agressivité des passions elle
n'est de l'incompréhension quant à quand
tu as un salaire et que tu vois ton
salaire tu as je sais pas moi 2000 euros
brut et que tu as que 1500 net tu sais
que les 500 c'est les charges c'est ça
qui fait marcher la sécurité sociale
mais en face tu as pas le service ouais
tu as pas de médecin ouais tu dis mais
moi je paye des cotisations mon patron
paye des cotisations et l'État a failli
à sa mission donc les gens dans un
premier temps ils comprennent pas ils
disent mais pourquoi moi j'ai pas de
médecin alors que je cotise et après
dans un deuxième moment ils sont en
colère et ils disent mais moi mon gamin
il a 40 degrés de fièvre moi j'ai deux
fils en bas âge si j'étais pas médecin
je me dirais mais j'ai pas de quoi les
faire soigner donc là tu es colérique et
l'intégresses et tu t'en prends aux
personnes qui sait ça qui sont devant
toi et nous on dit mais on comprend en
fait l'agressivité parce qu'en fait
l'État a rien fait pour vous la manif
qu'on a fait silencieuse c'était silence
il ne faut surtout pas réveiller les
gens qui ne font rien depuis 20 ans
donc nous on est juste là pour porter ce
message mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui c'est pas un problème de la
triple épidémie on essaie de faire
croire aux Français que le problème
c'est depuis le covid non mais tu as
combien de médecins de patients dans ta
patiente
en France on va pas dire que s'appelle
qui bosse pas
on veut vraiment revenir à une médecine
de famille on veut être là pour les gens
on veut soigner les gens il y a on veut
pas de la médecine de demain on veut de
la médecine d'avant on veut la médecine
on examine les gens on peut on a le
temps d'écouter les gens vraiment enfin
les gens veulent quand on était petit on
allait chez le médecin c'était comme ça
on allait à l'hôpital on était bien reçu
on veut pas de la médecine de demain
vous voulez la téléconsultation
on veut de la médecine d'avoir un type à
l'autre bout d'un écran quoi et c'est ça
qu'on nous vend Julien je vais vous dire
vous parlez de ça moi mon père est
médecin généraliste qui travaille encore
il a 75 il travaille encore et c'est
vrai que je le vois il a besoin même de
prendre le temps c'est important on va
chez le médecin on a besoin de lui
parler
tu peux pas faire ça à la chaîne tu peux
faire ça va pas faire ça et aujourd'hui
bien sûr et vous aujourd'hui c'est quoi
vos conditions en fait donc c'est quoi
1600 clients dans votre passé en fait
qu'on a fait des propositions pour en
recevoir encore plus parce qu'on est
vraiment débile dans le département en
fait c'est à dire que on a fait une
liste de propositions qui date d'il y a
un an qui n'avait pas été écouté envoyer
au députés en élection au sénateur
envoyé au président enfin pas au présent
mais aux candidat à la présidentielle et
c'est une liste de propositions où il y
a aucune revendication salariale où il y
a uniquement des choses très concrètes
qui peuvent permettre de libérer du
temps au médecin pour prendre plus de
patients c'est ça le truc et c'est des
choses très concrètes qui vous coûte
rien ça coûte rien contribuable et c'est
un choc de simplification administrative
entre autres il y a aussi des choses
innovantes comme par exemple comme en
Suisse ou dans les pays nordiques
permettent aux gens qui ont entre 18 et
65 ans de se faire eux-mêmes un arrêt de
travail quand ils sont malades ils ont
juste la grippe ou la gastro parce que
on a besoin d'aller voir un médecin
quand on est à la gastro on y va est-ce
qu'on a besoin d'un arrêt de travail
bien sûr et elle elle est pas médecin
généraliste à l'heure actuelle et les
médecins administratifs et juste là pour
gratter des papiers donc on fait des
propositions innovantes qu'on met sur la
table et on nous répond pas les députés
il y a personne etc on dénature nos
propos à chaque fois donc on est
tellement con qu'on qu'on va voir les
élus et qu'on leur dit bah on a déjà
deux fois plus de patients dans le reste
de la France mais on est capable d'en
prendre plus si vous faites ça et vous
savez vous savez ce qui se passe depuis
lundi on nous dit non on nous dit non ça
on retire ça on retire ça on fera pas on
est on est sur
ces mec-là qui en envoie les gendarmes
tu vois elle quand elle dit qu'elle a
1700 patients moi je suis passé 1700
patients il y a il y a 5 ans
accroche-toi à 2577 patients médecins
traitant qu'est-ce que tu crois qu'elle
fait ma secrétaire nous on libère des
plages quotidiennement et là les seuls
médecins généralistes actuellement
l'État leur colle une dixième année
d'étude 10 ans une dixième année d'étude
à faire exclusivement dans les déserts
médicaux sans la moindre incitation sans
le moindre encadrement donc voilà voilà
comment l'État nous parle actuellement
Elisabeth borne nous dit qu'on est
irresponsable mais irresponsable c'est
qui c'est qui ces gens-là qui donnent
pas les moyens aux jeunes médecins
généralistes d'exercer dans des
conditions correctes avec du personnel
avec des locaux correct pour accueillir
les patients avec des locaux corps et
pour accueillir les internes et faire en
sorte qu'il découvre cette médecine
générale qui est passionnante à exercer
moi je vais te dire je bosse demain je
vais être en grève avec eux je bosse pas
pour mon avenir je je suis je les
défends parce que je défends il
défendent une médecine de proximité les
moyens ça fait 50 ans je suis installé
50 ans
vous avez tous entendu que l'hôpital est
saturé dans toute la France et qui a
publie le problème moi quand j'étais
interne en 2010 il y avait déjà pas dit
les brancards dont on nous parle depuis
deux semaines c'est un mensonge d'État
en 2010 quand j'étais aux urgences il y
avait déjà les brancards
donc les éléments de langage politique
au bout d'un moment faut arrêter dans
mon département il y a une clinique à
l'heure actuelle qui a 70 litres ils
sont vides
ce que je peux me permettre
qui remplissent des fichiers Excel et
vous vous êtes juste héros dans un
tableur Excel pour aller dans votre sang
là ils ont bloqué 70 lits et on a une
clinique avec 70 litres qui sont libres
est-ce que c'est une réflexion et une
question vous êtes en train de soulever
un problème qui a été le même qu'on a
vécu en 2020 2021 les propositions des
cliniques qui avaient de l'espace des
lits et qui se proposaient de rendre
service et de participer on a dit non
c'est des administratifs pourquoi est-ce
que on va pas revenir sur les
vaccinations sur ces choses-là il y a
des personnels soignants suspendus on
manque de personnel pourquoi on en fait
pas k pourquoi il se passe des choses
qui sont toujours les administratifs des
cibles les ministères décident et les
gens qui sont sur le terrain se taisent
on vous a si ma mémoire est bonne
pendant la période grave du covid on a
demandé à des médecins de ne pas
prescrire j'ai pas inventé la chose
c'est qu'un ministre qui sait depuis un
mois qui va y avoir une fermeture des
cabinets que ce Ministre qui a les
moyens et on l'a vu réquisitionner les
médecins libéraux ne bouge pas il ne
fait rien
pourquoi parce que il veut laisser
pourrir la situation et surtout il sait
que les jeunes médecins parce que ce
sont les jeunes médecins qui sont à
l'origine de ce mouvement qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'exercer n'auront pas les
moyens de tenir la grève qu'ils vont
faire voilà voilà ce qui te fait si
responsabilité
chez le gouvernement parce que c'est pas
bon tout seul qui a refusé de
réquisitionner les gens t'inquiète pas
c'est le gouvernement parce que quand tu
entends madame born dire que les
médecins sont irresponsables etc
l'irresponsable c'est celui qui apparaît
guillonné moi en 50 ans d'exercices j'ai
jamais fermé mon cabinet pour Greg j'ai
fait une journée j'ai fait des manifs et
cetera
je suis parti sans remplaçant je suis
parti sans remplaçant en ce moment tu
vois et là moi aujourd'hui toi
normalement je suis en grève je suis
allé faire des de quatre visites chez
les personnes âgées qui sont en
difficulté etc les autres j'ai fait j'ai
fait totalement grève il y a 94 ans la
petite mémé de 94 ans que j'ai vu ce
matin tu vois j'avais le temps la
discuter avec eux je la connais depuis
74 elle m'a rappelé ma première
consultation 74 si tu veux et je connais
j'ai soigné son mari qui est décédé et
sa fille qui est décédée et cetera on a
parlé un peu tu vois la médecine de
famille c'est ça ils sont en train de la
détruire ils ne veulent pas ils ne
veulent plus de médecin généraliste ils
veulent remplacer il s'effrique pas de
la désertification ils veulent faire des
téléconsultation il y a des il y a des
plateformes de téléconsultation qui sont
en train de se goinfrer attention aucune
régulation etc donc si tu veux on
dégrade la qualité de prise en charge
des patients on donne pas les moyens aux
jeunes médecins de s'installer voilà
c'est tout c'est exceptionnel pour nous
parce que ça fait des années qu'on a des
choses à dire et qu'on ne donne jamais
la parole donc c'est vraiment je te
remercie Cyril on n'arrête pas depuis
des années vous mentir être une humour
exclusion on vous a dit que c'était
numéro exclusus c'est faux je vais vous
citer un chiffre on forme 4500 médecins
généralistes par an en France depuis 10
ans ça veut dire qu'on en a formé 45000
45000 ils sont où il y en a 10 % qui ont
arrêté complètement la médecine il y en
a que 10 % qui sont installés et il y en
a 15 % qui sont partis à l'étranger et
le reste ils font d'autres choses et ils
sont pas installés donc au lieu de dire
par démagogie oh mais c'est le
gouvernement d'avant puis c'est les
années 80 et puis vous savez on avait
bloqué alors maintenant faut former plus
attendez dans 10 ans bullshit on vous
ment c'est des écrans de fumée tout ça
c'est de la com le problème c'est que
dans les 4500 conformes par an il y en a
que 10% qui s'installe donc il faut
absolument faire en sorte que ces gens
là s'installe parce qu'en fait ils
existent donc arrêtons de vouloir
augmenter
sur les 25 euros tu sais comment ça
coûte et je vous aime prendre pour un
fou de donner cet exemple moi je prends
des cours de paddle tennis tu sais
comment ça coûte 90 euros exactement
je peux te dire il se lève le matin il
le sait Jean-Paul Cédric pareil il parle
le matin à 7h il revient le soir à 22h
je peux te dire et je le vois il compte
ses petits chèques et il fait ses petits
trucs tu vois 25 € + 25 € + 25 €, je
suis désolé 10 ans d'études 25 € la
configuration c'est pas possible
les médecins les moins bien payés
d'Europe mais c'est pas possible
il y a une femme qui est venue me voir
avec sa fille je suis spectacle une
heure de mitriaux j'avais demandé une
IRM la femme est venue me voir au bout
de trois semaines après le résultat de
l'IRM elle avait consulté un ostéopathe
qui lui avait remonté les organes qui
lui a pris combien et et elle avait
consulté une naturopathe qu'il avait
mise au régime donc 50 balles 70 balles
toi ces gens-là comment tu veux toi toi
tu as l'air d'un con avec tes 25 balles
tu vois et bien et je te dis pas le mec
qui avait été voir le magnétiseur pour
ça pour sa sciatique bien sûr tu sais
que 25 la balle en étant généraliste qui
a fait mais moi quand je te dis quand
j'ai vu mon père j'ai toujours vu mon
père en train de le soir revenir avec sa
manette à 10h30 du soir il a travaillé
toute la journée il compte combien il
avait et tu sais combien il doit faire
de clients par jour peut-être il
travaille encore il a 75 ans il
travaille encore arrête mais regarde
bien tu te rends compte on est à
l'Allemagne tu veux que je te dis c'est
un manque de respect métier
le coup de la vie beaucoup moins cher
ils sont à 40 €, c'est anormal en plus
ils n'ont même pas parlé de salaire ils
en ont même pas parlé
de conditions bien sûr de conditions
d'exercice quand vous peur de conditions
d'exercice c'est-à-dire qu'un type de
travail avec un secrétariat avec des
locaux corrects dans des conditions
correctes avec un secrétariat d'accueil
alors la plupart des médecins si mes
deux j'ai deux extrémités que j'ai vu à
la manifestation 1er décembre ce qui m'a
frappé tu vois c'est de voir qu'il y
avait 70% de jeunes femmes et parmi ces
70 % de jeunes femmes il y avait deux de
musique internes qui sont installés
depuis 5 ans et me dit tu sais Jean-Paul
si ça continue à 25 €, je vais obligé de
licencier ma femme de ménage
donc parce que parce que les gens parce
que les jeunes médecins ils ont raison
ils veulent pas bosser 60 heures comme
les vieux cons comme moi ils ont envie
d'avoir une vie de famille ils ont envie
de pouvoir accueillir leurs enfants etc
et que quand tu bosses 40 ou 45 heures à
25 € en médecine générale quand
accueille correctement les gens tu peux
pas t'en sortir et c'est ça et c'est ça
qui est c'est ça que ces jeunes là sont
en train de faire moi je trouve
inadmissible et je le dis parce que vous
n'avez pas parlé les 25 les 25 €, c'est
un scandale
c'était plus payé que mon père
combien tu payes de mutuelle faut qu'il
rembourse ces ostéopathes et les
naturopathes 43 milliards 43 milliards
permettent aux médecins généralistes et
au médecin spécialiste de bosser avec du
personnel correct parce qu'il y a
correctement les patients ah bien sûr
43 milliards les mutuelles 9 milliards
de frais de gestion dans beaucoup de
frais pour la pub alors
mais mais 9 milliards de frais de
gestion la marge elle est là tu veux que
je te dise tu veux que je te dise en
plus et je vais dire vous allez dire si
je dis une connerie ou pas même le fait
que ce soit 25 euros je te jure que les
médecins généralistes sont pas assez
considérés parce que quand tu vas faire
quand tu vas chez
thermaliste
mais bien sûr si tu crois quoi
et je tiens à dire on paye pas on avance
les frais et on la rembourser exactement
donc quand j'entends des gens dire quoi
50 on n'aura pas les moyens mais vous
avez pas les moyens la rembourser en 48
heures avec la carte Vitale non mais
c'est pas quelqu'un qui paye on n'a
jamais demandé aux gens et justement et
ça les dérange pas de payer 110 euros
pour aller voir un spécialiste mais 25 €
le généraliste parce que c'est c'est
c'est le système qui a fait ça
aujourd'hui c'est le premier roi de la
prévention parce que au final ça fera
des économies évidemment d'avoir un bon
journal un bon généraliste qui passera
avec toi bien sûr parlera qui sera le
terrain évidemment c'est un mauvais
calcul on a plus de consultation simple
c'est que des consultations
franchement en Eure-et-Loir exactement
on est c'est vrai il y a un de mes
patients qui me l'a dit il m'a dit vous
m'avez diagnostiqué un cancer à 25 euros
après là il faut qu'on il y a pas que
l'argent nous on peut là on n'a pas nous
rejoindre
nous ce qu'on veut ce qu'on veut c'est
qu'on veut que nos patients un médecin
on veut que les Aurélien veut que on
veut que les Français ils aient un
médecin
un Aurélien sur trois une autre
département nous on veut que on veut que
le ministre absolument vient dans notre
département
qu'on a faites qui ne coûte rien au
contribuable et où on demande même pas
de revalorisation de la consultation on
veut que le ministre qui vient dire le
29 décembre que s'il était jeune il ne
serait plus médecin qui l'assume il
devrait pas terminé
dans le département parce que c'est
quand même 150 km de Paris donc il peut
venir et qu'il écoute nos propositions
et qui nous disent oui ce sont une
proposition de bon sens on va vous aider
pour sortir les patients de la merde
parce que là les gens ils vont crever
donc c'est la plus possible Guillaume
toi je crois que tu étais un peu
d'accord avec lui non plus non non moi
non non
mais moi ça me choque je joue au Cercle
le salaire moyen et haut mais il faut
voir dans quelles conditions il est
gagné c'est des gens qui font énormément
d'horaires et j'ai lu que je crois que
quelqu'un qui fait une consultation à
domicile gagne 4 € dans sa poche c'est
ça mais tu sais non tu sais ce qui est
ce qui est terrible tu vois c'est que ce
métier on oublie que tu es confronté tes
confronté quoi la maladie naturellement
à la mort à la fragilité de l'existence
et je vais dire moi j'ai une de mes
associés une semaine elle avait dans la
même semaine elle a vu une gamine qui
avait une tumeur cérébrale et une autre
qui avait une leucémie qui avait le même
âge que ses gamines je vais te dire tu
rentres chez toi tu es pas
tranquillement or la pénibilité de ce
métier la difficulté de ce métier elle
est complètement niée par par des par
des par des gouvernants qui qui pensent
que on est des lentilles des fainéants
etc les jeunes ils demandent ils
demandent de bosser dans des conditions
correctes on parle des tarifs mais les
tarifs ils ont pas été augmentés si tu
veux le tarif de de dimanche il a pas
été il y a 19 euros 06 de majoration ça
veut dire que ça pas été augmenté depuis
l'Euro bien sûr l'euro il date de 2002
donc tu vois donc il y a des tas de
tarifs qui n'ont pas été augmenté depuis
2002 les chirurgiens les chirurgiens qui
opèrent une vésicule il y a il y a 30
ans qui faisait une cicatrice de 20 cm
10 jours d'hospitalisation maintenant
ils ont changé leur façon d'exercer si
tu as une célioscopie était dehors le
soir même ces gens-là qui ont économisé
fait économiser 10 jours
d'hospitalisation qui ont changé leur
technique le tarif de l'ablation de la
vésicule c'est le même qui a 20 ans donc
après on dit ils font des compléments
d'honoraires mais bordel les compléments
d'honoraires ils les ont pas volé parce
que depuis 20 ans les tarifs ils ont un
petit peu augmenté quand même tu vois et
donc c'est ça l'affaire il faut dire
aussi il faut dire c'est que c'est les
patients mais c'est tous les soignants
en Europe
moi j'ai des mes infirmières au cabinet
elles veulent arrêter le arrêter leur
travail elles empêchent plus elles
veulent arrêter le soin
destinés sont un bout tous les tout le
personnel soignante que ça soit de
l'hôpital que ça soit en ville c'est
très compliqué et on veut juste on veut
soigner on veut aider les gens du
déplacement d'une infirmière à domicile
dis donc 2,50 € et alors et alors quand
il y a eu l'augmentation du prix de
l'essence l'État dans sa grande
générosité à accorder 4 centimes
d'augmentation 4 centimes d'augmentation
c'est à dire que le médecin il se
déplace à domicile pour 10 euros et 4
centimes et l'infirmière pour 2 euros 54
centimes et là cette mesure vient de
s'arrêter je demande comment ils vont
faire les gens merci merci
à vous trois ma mère m'a dit tu as
raison papa s'est crever le cul pour 23
euros alors que Gilles Verdez vient
mettre son cul sur la chaîne pour dire
j'ai mal à ma France pour beaucoup plus
que ça donc voilà
[Applaudissements]